hello there i'm abby sharp welcome to a
special edition of Abby's kitchen called
toilet talk where we dig through the
bowels of information out there to help
you have healthier happier poops now
we've got a question here from our
friend Becky let's take a look-see Dear
Abby every week I have a few days where
I get so constipated I feel like a
balloon about to burst with poop
Oh God Christ please do not pop my
mother-in-law says it could be dairy or
meat or chocolate or bread but I tried
cutting out all those things and
nothing's helping I sometimes take a
laxative but what can I do to unplug
naturally so that I can go back to my
comfortable routine signed backed up
Becky
okay well Becky first of all we all have
occasional constipation and let's be
honest it is the shot but I don't want
anyone in my near vicinity bursting like
a balloon with poop so let's go through
some basics here first of all I know
you'll probably be really happy to hear
this but your mother-in-law was probably
wrong there is no strong research out
there to suggest that any one food
causes constipation not bread not dairy
not meet and not chocolate
what does tend to cause occasional
constipation is what I call the trifecta
of unfortunate poopy circumstances not
enough fiber not enough water and not
enough exercises let's go through each
of these one by one first up let's talk
fiber fiber helps you hold water in your
stool bulk it up and then move that bad
boy along so I can join its friends in
the pool so aim to get around 25 grams
of fiber each day if you're a woman and
38 grams each day if you're a man and
you can do that from sources like wheat
bran pulses whole grains fruits
vegetables and psyllium
prunes pears and apples may be
particularly helpful because they
contain a sugar alcohol called sorbitol
and that has a natural laxative effect
number two
hydration fiber is just going to leave
you even more backed up if you don't
have enough water to blast that crap out
of you
so aim to drink water throughout the day
and
look at your pee in the toilet if you
see a bright yellow color you know it's
time to up the hydration where if you
see a pale young color you know you're
in the clear and finally get moving
think of every step on the treadmill as
shifting and squeezing that food down
your large intestine plus exercise
increases your heart rate and breathing
which stimulates natural contractions in
your test time to help to get that fit
out also you'll want to try to chill out
as for laxative unless your doctor
prescribed them girl I definitely
suggest you hold back honestly it is way
too easy to get caught up in a cycle of
laxative overuse which can lead to
electrolyte imbalances bloating and even
weight gain but of course as always
definitely speak to your doctor before
starting or stopping a laxative machine
well backed up Becky I hate for you to
have to change your name but I hope the
next time I see you you'll be going by
something else as for the rest of you I
want to know what some of your toilet
troubles are so no shame no judgement
just leave me a comment below and I'll
answer your questions in an upcoming
video if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
this special edition of boiler talk at a
peace kitchen did you hear about the
constipate a composer he had problems
with his last movement
you